let's bring in Chris Mannix Chris
obviously covers the NBA but also boxing
I don't know if I'm breaking the news to
you here Chris I'm sorry if I am but
does Sweet Pea Whitaker dying at the age
of 55 yeah and I I just saw him recently
he he hangs around with his former
promoter at main events at a lot of the
major shows you know being just to add
on to everything you said there maybe
the best defensive fighter ever I mean
he and like really pep from long before
then and we talk about it often with
Floyd because Floyd considers himself
the best offensive fighter but I think
Pernell Whitaker was the best defensive
fighter I've ever seen all right some
basketball here we got Jerry West coming
up next hour I don't know what role he
played in this is there any Jerry West
greater as a front office personnel or
player I mean it's really close I mean
Jerry I don't look Jerry well I think
I'll be the first to admit that he was
involved in the middie Gritty of it you
know that belonged to Lawrence Frank of
course and michael winger who you know
came over from oklahoma city at a
relationship with sam presby for a
number of years that really helps kind
of grease the skids and get that Paul
George deal in motion I think Jerry's
involvement from everything I've been
told is that you know when there were
there was some uncertainty about whether
to pull the trigger
I think Jerry's voice was pretty strong
that you know we do this deal that you
only get opportunities like this every
so often and even though the price is
high you have to make this deal I think
that's where Jerry kind of came in as
one of the stronger voices to absolutely
do it I applaud you because when you
don't know then you tell me you don't
know but when you do then you usually
have you know cite sources I the
beginning the one thing I know that I I
don't know is anything that Kawhi
Leonard is going to do like I just don't
and even I said I get more nervous
because I thought Durant from the outset
was going to the Knicks
I had base that off nothing other than a
gut feel and the closer we got the more
people saying that he was going to the
Knicks the more I thought he's not going
to the Knicks like these are too you
know they're very unique players one is
very public and one is very private but
you know with Kauai going to the
Clippers how long do you think he made
up his mind he was going to the Clippers
I don't look I don't think it was I
don't think he's had this sort of result
in his head that he was going to the
Clippers I think there were in fact I
know there were plenty of people I guess
plenty who strong were there up that
many people around him but people in his
inner circle liked the idea of the
Clippers you know as I've said and
written the Clippers had been shadow
recruiting him kind of all season long
and and they were were very much he was
their top priority all throughout but if
the Raptors had been able to come to
some kind of agreement where they took
on Paul George I think I would have gone
back there I mean this was like I don't
know who you vote for for executive of
the Year my vote by the way goes to s
Isley Jenkins
you know who's over the Clippers as well
so I think we'll give him an exec of the
Year vote shout-out Lee Jenkins but I
mean Kawhi Leonard is you know kind of
part of that process like he sort of
orchestrated this you know and said
whatever team gets me or gets Paul
George
I'm gonna find my way there and he got
the Clippers to potentially sacrifice
their long-term future but a chance to
win multiple championships in the next
three or four years that that was I mean
I nope nobody saw that coming and that's
why he's just a he just he's a very
difficult guy to read and a hard guy to
predict anything's gonna happen with
alright and then you get Paul George so
we asked the question our poll question
is who's gonna go farther the Lakers or
the Clippers it's overwhelming the
Clippers
that's surprised you don't know nah I
mean are they better than the Lakers oh
definitely
I mean you know Danny I sat here I was
the first one I think to say to you last
year that the Lakers were a combustible
group yes it's the same thing this year
like we're
I mean they're more talented at the very
top with Anthony Davis but you're
bringing back a lot of the same cast of
characters and you you add on to it the
you know Melrose Place like situation
with the coaching staff where you know
if Frank Vogel loses like two of the
first three games its Vogel watch out
there wait wait wait you just quoted
Melrose Place I was thinking about my
headache drama I mean I guess I could
have gone now - I know I mean that's
more my wheelhouse you're sad okay
the Lakers who really makes you nervous
the player on the Lakers that really
makes me nervous I would still say Rondo
you know and I just don't know like the
Lakers did some nice things towards the
very end I'm a big every Bradley guy I
mean there's a lot of people that
watched him play for the Clippers to
think he kind of washed but 4:28 you're
not paying them like max level money
he's a two-way player that I think could
be helpful but I think Rondo if Rhonda's
got to play a key role again and and
he's on a one-year deal it's like a
number of these other guys are basically
on one plus one or two year deals it's
the same type of problem where you have
guys oh no what am I talking about
DeMarcus Cousins that's easy I forgot he
assigned there a better guy what am I
talking about like that's a guy that you
know he went through we went through
last year thinking it was going to lead
to a big contract and he's making less
this year in his next deal and is a
pretty good chance he's not going to
start so you know how does that all play
itself out now Anthony Davis wanted to
play with DeMarcus Cousins that was
clear and Rondo has a strong
relationship from Sacramento with
DeMarcus Cousins but how's that gonna
work when he's coming off the bench and
looking at you know age 30 and another
year going by where he's not earning
himself a top level contract that no
brainer toughest toughest one there then
you got the Rockets with they bring in
Westbrook and then they they finally
dump Chris Paul and
okay okay see gets traffic's let me
start with OKC and then we'll circle
back to Westbrook and the Rockettes
it's Billy Donovan more likely to stay
now given this young team with draft
picks and you know they'll get rid of
Chris Paul at some point but or could
you see Billy Donovan saying I'm gonna
pull the ripcord on this and get out of
this go back to college yeah I think
it's it's it's gonna be a conversation I
don't know if it goes just go back to
college there might be another pro
opportunity out there for him at some
point or look this isn't what Billy
Donovan signed up for he signed up to
coach Kevin Durant and Russell Westbrook
and he left a great job at Florida for
that and look it's you know guys going
to the pros I mean it's their dreams
they don't feel with recruiting and all
the machination that go through college
so I don't think Billy Don's gonna run
back to the college ranks but if another
pro opportunity presented itself I don't
know maybe consider that I think that's
gonna have to be a conversation because
this is the very very very long game
that that Oklahoma City is playing I do
think then that they had as good a toss
cues as anybody because that team at
plateaued like I don't care what was
happening next year wasn't winning
anything and you know from my
conversations with people on that side
of the fence you know there was a very
real possibility that if they flamed out
early next year that they were gonna
have to be proactive in moving some of
these guys especially Paul George
because in his contract situation and
wouldn't have got anywhere near the hole
back in return I mean think about what
happened there like a confluence of
events that Paul George asked for a
trade to a team that was desperate to
trade forums that gave up a record hall
record haul of assets they got assets
back for Russell Westbrook as of like
Thursday it's summer league den I'm
asking around it executives of teams if
I was interested in Russell Westbrook
and I was getting some pretty emphatic
knows including from like the Detroit of
the world like teams you might see you
might see envision Russell Westbrook
going there but they got assets back in
exchange for Russell Westbrook and I
think at some point they're just gonna
flip Chris Paul off to Miami when they
can make those numbers work so I think
Oklahoma City had a tremendous you know
last couple of weeks in making these
deals
we proposed last hour that maybe the
Rockettes to make this work with James
Harden and Russell Westbrook jr. the
third is you platoon them you have
harden with the first group and then
Westbrook comes off the bench with the
second group that you rotate them how do
they make this work in Houston well I
mean that's you have to do that for
starters I mean that's kind of what they
had they did with Chris Paul anyway and
it's what Billy Donovan did with Durant
and Russell Westbrook if you go back to
that one year like Durant started and
then came out of the game in like the
six-minute mark like he was gone and
then they became they start staggering
those minutes but the problem becomes
like in the fourth quarter how do you
make it all work like how does it all
come together because Russell Westbrook
is not the player that you would vision
being successful playing off of James
Harden he's just not a shooter and he's
never gonna be a shooter so you whoever
is guarding Russell Westbrook when
hardens has at the ball is gonna be able
to be a de facto double-team like every
time so when I talked in this broke just
I was leaving Vegas but in talking to
some some head coaches out there one
thing that was consistent was that you
know Mike D'Antoni is gonna have to have
a long conversation with Harden about
playing off the ball more like he's
gonna have to inept you know a different
type of role and you know theoretically
you know hardens done that in Oklahoma
City but that was a lifetime ago
I mean a lifetime at a different player
ago it's just um there were a lot of
like sort of like you know head
scratching what's when it came to this I
think the deal was more about getting
off Chris Paul and then realizing that
relationship wasn't working but you know
this one
I just from purely basketball since I
don't and they're really and I haven't
talked to everybody but there's not a
lot of people that I've talked to that
that's the easy way this makes sense
what are your expectations for Golden
State this year depending on how clay
comes back and when he comes back
there's he could win the conference like
really good like that's yeah I look
across the west and I see every team of
question marks like there's no I mean
look I like what I love what the
Clippers did but I mean who they're
starting four and five like their front
court
is still you know kind of decimated at
this point and there have to you know
pick the buyout market pretty clean to
get some of these guys that that might
be available I kind of sneaky like what
the Warriors did to recover I mean yeah
I like really cauley-stein in that makes
athletic big who's gonna play off you
know you know guys like Steph and run
the floor really well I mean I know they
lost it without of course to rant but
you know they did a nice job in
recovering and signing some lower key
type of players now clay is obviously
the most important piece of this if he
comes back in like late March and never
it is not the same player for the rest
of the season you know their first-round
potential fodder but if he comes back in
like February and is able to get his
legs under him by the time April rolls
around the ACL injury as you know then
it's not as devastating as it used to be
the Achilles injury is terrifying the
ACL injury just as a matter of when not
if a guy gets it back so if clay gets it
back on playoff time you know the
experience of that team and and like
draymond I mean that they're they're a
team that could win that conference can
Kevin Durant come back this season I
don't got the press conference for for
the nets in Vegas and I wrote a whole
piece well kind of the inner workings of
it in a magazine this past week I don't
know what the nets are doing like all
the all the smart moves they made I
don't know what they're doing in leaving
the door open for Kevin Durant to come
back like it just doesn't make any sense
whatsoever haven't they learned from
what Golden State did when they the
owners said that Kevin is coming back
and then we put him on the clock and
then he felt pressured to come back like
the last thing I want is him to feel
pressured to come back the only thing I
can think of then is like the day before
they had that press conference
Sean marks had a sit-down meeting with
Kevin Durant for the first time and
maybe Kevin Durant told him like don't
rule me out you never know what I can do
when when they get into you know like
that they know the timetable but the
doctor and now they've been able to talk
the doctor like officially like the
doctor for Kevin Durant is the pain
doctor pinettes there's no way that that
he's going to tell them to like be
optimistic about this like this is
consistent you know nine to twelve month
injury it was on the short end you're
talking about like April of getting him
back and that's that's insane like if
you're you know the six eat the plants
gonna bring Kevin Durant back and drop
him in for fifteen minutes a night
coming off an Achilles injury
let this be a redshirt year as most
people expect is going to be anyway and
take that off the table like if they if
they get to training camp and don't rule
him out I'm gonna be surprised because
leaving the door open for now I guess
doesn't really hurt anybody there's no
games being played in the NBA thankfully
is gonna like fade off into the sunset
for the next month or so but the way to
make it to training camp I mean let it
go man like do not have this become a
monthly thing we reacting tener asking
how close Durant's progress when's he
coming back
final 30 seconds did does ion deserve to
be criticized for being out of shape in
the summer league no he deserves be
criticized if he's other shape and
training camp like you know the guy
probably hasn't played a minute of
competitive basketball since Duke got
eliminated from the tournament yeah he
was out of shape and there are a lot of
guys I saw out there that rather seen
top-tier guys the handful of them that
played know he's got a lot of work to do
you know before he gets into training
camp but he becomes September he's able
to give you a 35 minutes a night this is
all forgotten Thank You Chris we
appreciate it as always that's Chris
Mannix the senior NBA writer for Sports
Illustrated for more Dan Patrick show
tune in the audience channel 239 on
directv stream for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show at
[Music]